hello there guys it looks like we've
been given our first look at modok
through some leaked images i'm going to
show and break down for you guys right
now so in this first image here it seems
to be the top of his head we can see his
eyes here judging by this picture it
seems that his armor is made of this
gold-like material but in the next image
which is of his uh next last chest area
we do see some silver here now before i
go on to address the fan complaints
about not having his usual face design
from the comics i'm going to show a fan
recreation of what he apparently looks
like from the movie as a whole instead
of just seeing his head and neck so here
is modoc which seems to line up pretty
good to the leaks that i just showed you
apart from the neck slash chest area
unless if i just forgot to include it in
this fan creation and this does line up
pretty well from a merchandising league
which i'll show you guys here now the
one big complaint with this design is
that it's not like the usual comic
design we get to see his face and that
is okay because i have heard that this
won't be the only time we'll see murdoch
apparently we'll see him in other future
marvel projects median we could see his
character design change and evolve over
time and becoming the more comic
accurate design that a lot of people
wanted to see or perhaps in ant-man and
a wasp over the course of the movie we
could see his armor get destroyed or
damaged which will cause him to ditch
that armor mask that we see and then
we'll just see his normal face so
there's a couple of things that could
happen but in the meantime this is all
the information and all of the images
that we have of modoc so let me know
what you think of his current design in
the comments section below and are you
guys excited to see him and ant-man and
the wasp quantomania thanks for watching
guys